[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour contrer les prévisions alarmistes
du diabolique olivier delamarche dans ce
tir marquage on va faire preuve d'un peu
plus d'optimisme et vous vivrez des
pronostics positifs pour 2022 et on
parle pas de la coupe du monde de foot
moi au contraire je tirais technique à
main ce serait une bonne chanson déjà
2022 pourrait sonner le retour à la vie
normale le ministre de la santé a déjà
évoqué que la vague omicron pourrait
être la dernière
l'épidémiologiste en chef du danemark
avance même une date de fin de pandémie
d'ici deux mois la forte contamination
du variant et sa dangerosité moindre
permettrait d'atteindre sereinement une
immunité collective
du côté des banques centrales 2022
pourrait être la fin ou le début de la
fin du déversement de liquidités aux
états unis jérôme peau elle a évoqué en
fin d'année christine lagarde a été plus
prudente mais allez on veut croire à une
reconnexion des marchés boursiers et de
l'économie réelle pas facile vu les
records de hausse des bourses en 2021
enfin une victoire d'un candidat à la
présidentielle qui saura ramener de la
sérénité économique au pays voire de la
sérénité tout court d'ailleurs après une
crise sanitaire qui aura créé des
déficits stratosphérique et une dette
abyssale on ne sait jamais ça pourrait
arriver à est bon quand même une
victoire de la france à la prochaine
coupe du monde tant qu'à faire au
contraire puis effectivement je pense
que c'est faisable temps qu'on a à me
bat p est une bonne année à tous sens de
la part du tiroir cachot
e
[Musique]